trans members of this family all love
each other
[Music]
i'm not a woman so i
i can't really answer that what is wrong
with these people these are the people
with four college degrees
matt walsh dude's a g works for the
daily wire conserved a guy with a very
big brain did a documentary called what
is a woman where he simply asks these
people what is a woman
i can't believe this is something that
we have to watch and give our thoughts
to but you know what does the world come
to you know there's more to being a
woman than just than just not having a
penis so don't don't get all sensitive
and crazy on me here
with the fluidity of these things
how do i know if if i'm a woman you know
i
that's a great question i like scented
candles yeah i've watched sex in the
city yeah
um yeah
so how do i know yeah matt that question
right there like that question
is
like when it's asked with a lot of
curiosity right that's the beginning of
a lot of people's like gender identity
development journeys if my mom who gave
birth to me is
a woman
and my wife is a woman
though i haven't asked her
maybe i should um
this this chick it
she's looking at me
yeah like like he just said the most
meaningful thing ever like am i really a
woman i mean what is wrong with these
people these are the people with four
college degrees i just can't imagine
having so much time and so little
responsibility in my life that i had the
time to like like how much how much
laying around and contemplating [ __ ] do
you have to do to get to that question
that's so deep in the in the in the list
of [ __ ] that needs to be figured out and
dealt with that's what people it's not
even on the list for for me like am i am
i actually a woman it's because they
want to keep you distracted with
[ __ ] issues like this so you can't
see the true crazy stuff that's going on
you can't look into where all your tax
dollars are going no one's focusing on
the important stuff how our eyes lit up
like how everyone's just getting banned
on social media for speaking against the
truth they they they brainwashed these
people into worrying and and making
their life's purpose issues like this
which are complete [ __ ] issues and
not even real person how could you go to
a person and actually try to worm into
their brain that they might not be what
they're perfectly comfortable being like
i know some people there's they i read a
statistic and i i will be happy to look
it up and verify that at some point in
their lives about three percent of
people children will have gender
dysphoria and by the time they're adults
it's about one percent of the entire
earth's population that has it and
they're trying to make it mainstream why
why why do we need this how is this
making life better for anybody forcing
children to to get confused about
whether they're a girl or a boy what is
that song really what am i missing what
does that solve i don't know putting it
in kids shows is only harming them when
when you're telling them crazy [ __ ] like
when you're showing little kids that
like little impressionable kids i don't
think you guys realize how stupid little
kids are they're the most their brains
are sponges they're extremely
impressionable if all that they consume
on tv when they're little is is
transgender fishes and [ __ ] it's
gonna [ __ ] with their heads families
families marching four by four hurrah
hurrah
trans members of this family all love
each other so proudly and they are
marching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe it won't you know what we don't
know yet no it's going to we do not know
the long-term uh implications of this
they're trying to make it mainstream but
a little kid could watch all that and
also watch nemo and mickey mouse and all
the things and wake up and think that
those [ __ ] are just [ __ ] disney
characters and carry on and still be the
same person at the end of the day you
know and then they're turned the
transgenders are going to be treated
like cartoon characters instead of real
people so who knows we don't know let's
see how this pans out but if they're all
women and also the boy sits down with
you and says i think i'm a girl actually
is one then then what is a woman
yeah
great question i'm not a woman so i
i can't really answer that
dog
i would literally bet my entire crypto
wallet that if you look between this
this person's legs there wouldn't be a
dangly thing i don't care if you think
you're a sheep dog
and you come into my store
it don't matter to me just don't come in
and try to shove that [ __ ] down my
throat if it makes someone feel better
what about their feelings i don't give a
[ __ ] about their feelings i'm old
they're on the star wars universe what
about my feelings what if i'm not
comfortable saying that your feelings
don't matter as long as their feelings
aren't hurt your comfort level doesn't
matter yeah your values your convictions
the things that matter to you do not
matter you must conform or be silenced
jar jar binks
pansexual do you think it's actually
insane because you can't even say normal
stuff like there's only two genders like
literally you it gets taken off it gets
taken off of social media
every video i've seen of the clip of us
talking with sneka where he asked us how
many genders there are every single
video got deleted it didn't really yeah
tell me that they would get millions of
views and they get deleted for saying
there's two genders two genders still
imagine that that's where we are that
literally saying there's two genders
like one of the most known facts ever
replacing rampant inflation crime is the
worst that's been in decades in this
country
the we are on the brink of world war
three and you've got people worrying
about [ __ ] pronouns what at least in
the 60s when the kids were rebelling and
they were creating you know protesting
and all that it was it was about a real
injustice a major war and real civil
unjustice civil rights this [ __ ] oh my
god these people need a cause a real
cause the [ __ ] out of here it's
infuriating can't [ __ ] out of here why
why why would i even care it's if it's
his truth
well it ain't true you're not a
scientist you're not a gender studies
major or are you
no okay how do you know that you're a
man how do i know that i might i guess
because i got a dick
so what
what is a woman
why do you ask that question
i just really like tonight
what do you think the answer to that
question is
oh
uh what's to play answer questions
i'm asking that's why i came to a
college professor who
this is your this is what you do
what other kinds of answers have you
gotten
none
a lot of like this where you're where
you're not answering i've got a lot of
that so i think it's interesting that
you that you say that some of the people
you've you've um interviewed have been
i'm reluctant to answer it and i think
that has a lot to do with the way the
questions that preceded it and the the
way that you've conducted yourself in
the interview how have i conducted
myself
how do you think you've conducted
yourself oh my
god he's like this guy is like if this
is a college professor this is who
people are paying 40 000 a year to learn
from it's a scam this is who you're
learning from are you [ __ ] kidding me
so this guy oh my god holy
you just really don't want to answer the
questions do you
i i came today very willing and
enthusiastic about answering questions
about women and gender sexuality studies
which is so you wanted to do you wanted
to answer questions about women's
studies and so shouldn't the the first
answer you should be able to provide is
what exactly is a woman well it's it for
me it's it's actually a really simple
answer and that's a person who
identifies as a woman but what are they
identifying as
as a woman what is that
as a woman
oh mom do you know what a circular
definition is
i do
it's sort of like
what you're doing right now where a
woman is is a woman
because you're seeking what we would
call in my field of work an essentialist
definition of gender i think it sounds
like you would like me to give you a set
of biological or cultural
characteristics that are associated with
one gender or the other i'm not seeking
any type of definition i'm just seeking
a definition yeah and i gave you one no
you didn't all right that guy is like if
you took k for sutherland and you
stripped all of the reason and
masculinity and coldness out of him
that's what you'd have left
and just based on what he looks like
which is foolish and not an intelligent
commentary but i couldn't help it he
looks like he for if kiefer was what
does he see what is a dog someone who
identifies as a dog like he didn't give
an answer a woman is someone who
identifies as a woman but okay
what is a woman he wouldn't answer holy
[ __ ] this is like this hurts to watch it
it does hurt to watch it's ridiculous
just because you identify as a woman
doesn't make you a woman it makes you a
transgender man or woman i don't i can't
even keep up this is what i literally
had to deal with at public school was
teachers just like this and it it
literally that wouldn't answer a
question for you and no how do you think
you're connecting yourself how do you
think you're conducting the people oh my
god how did he not just pounce and choke
him to death i couldn't i can't talk to
people that can't have a conversation
and this is somebody like you said at
forty thousand dollars at a state school
people are paying eighty thousand
dollars at a private university it's a
crazy thing
literally every single teacher thinks
like that literally all of them
obviously not every single one but for
the most part every teacher is
left-leaning and things like that so
even the students when they're
submitting their work they have to they
have to switch the way they write it to
conform to that so that the teacher
agrees with them and those people don't
get cancelled yeah so they don't fail
out or get cancelled yeah i literally
need to like agree with the teacher to
even to even pass it's all such a scam i
can't i can't say it enough like every
day that goes on i look into college
[ __ ] more i'm like holy [ __ ] this just
just even it just gets even worse uh at
what age can a child first
begin to
transition into another gender or
identify themselves as
a gender different from how they were
born yeah well i mean there's there's
research and data that show that um
babies and infants um understand
differences in gender this is hard to
this is frustrating and painful to watch
go ahead just just what a rip these are
people who are physically able-bodied
but feel like they should be disabled or
identify as such for example a man who
has two arms but feels like you should
have one if uh if a man in this kind of
marginalized community was went to the
doctor and said i want to have
my arm cut off
do you think that that doesn't have
anything to do with gender identity
well it's uh someone's
someone's self-identity you know
something that's
that's someone who has a um
a
and i'll accept it as a mental diagnosis
let her finish let her finish
i don't even pretend to know what
epimenophilia is all about but somehow
it's the idea that you when you you know
you're fascinated or charmed by having a
limb or part of a limb missing
okay i would say that's
uh
don't say pardon my non-medical language
cookie
oh you don't see any
do you think this is totally irrelevant
yup
hmm okay yeah no wait wait wait wait
wait chocolate is directly related so if
you want to chop your arm off and
identify as a one-armed person that's
not crazy but if you literally want to
chop your dick off it's not crazy yeah
it's fine it's not a condition it's not
gender dysphoria which is exactly what
it is oh boy here goes the
death threats
and okay and i and you know what we're
saying this i'm coming from a place of i
don't care who's transgender i have no
problem with it i i don't i've said it
before be just as wonderful and talented
and contributing to your own life and
society and do whatever you want but
let's not pretend that a biological male
is a woman and and a biological woman is
a male and now we can have pregnant men
we can't can't have pregnant men it's a
woman who dresses like a man who's now
pregnant and i'll call that person steve
or frank or whatever he wants me to
because i'm polite and i have good
manners but not because i believe that
sheila is now steve and is magically
steve because she cut her off a name is
also just a name so if anyone can
legally change their name there's
nothing wrong with that i'm just using
that the name as the the thing that
always means
it's like they them [ __ ] it's like they
and them is a plural in the english
language why the [ __ ] do i have to refer
to one person i'm not i'm not doing it
i'm not doing it i'm not i i like
grammar writer i have that freaking have
grammar guides and i use them online and
in print all the time no not using they
to talk about one person not happening
you're not changing it you're not
[ __ ] with the language too i'd
literally rather if i had to do it i'd
rather use a unique pronoun for that
person rather than yeah make something
up that that we can all get behind but
you're gonna which i think those are
stupid too try to wreck the language
that's that's how little problems you
have in your life that you need to make
a big worry is what people call you
that's what that's a sign that you you
need to go out and make some money you
you need you need imagine like that they
get people fired for using that for
using the wrong pronouns and saying
things wrong so i have a name that's
hard to say i'm not going to say it my
whole life i've been called in school
and in business and in social situations
by random variations on that name and i
just answer i'm like i don't care i'm
not gonna get into a huff about it
that's not how you say my name like if
it's somebody that i'm gonna have an
ongoing relationship with i'll correct
them just so they're not embarrassed ten
years later when they find out the truth
but really are we this sensitive that we
have to walk around constantly berating
people for either honest mistakes or
even if they're deliberate get over it
dog this hurts it hurts it does hurt and
it makes me sad that this whole
generation of people are this [ __ ]
mentally ill and incapable of dealing
with life there's no mental strength in
this entire population of people who are
acting this way and you know what and i
think they're probably misrepresenting a
lot of transgender people we just don't
hear from them because if they say
anything like look at um caitlyn jenner
when she says anything disagreeing with
the the the left narrative they tear her
apart you know it's like the same thing
the average joe can't can't you know who
is a transgender person doesn't have the
money and power and security of caitlyn
jenner so they can't speak out so that
there's got to be more like caitlyn
jenner who were just like please guys
shut up you're ruining it for us it's
the same thing when when there's a black
conservative or someone doesn't or like
a black person that doesn't agree with
like the black lives matter organization
they just go and call them like uncle
tom like the pig like pikmi masa like
they they just make jokes oh my god my
favorite is when they call them black
white supremacists like real okay
because they literally have different
ideologies because they're not allowed
hey wait the president said it when he
was running hey if you don't vote for me
you ain't black
what oh
it was i'm paraphrasing but i know i
literally went in there
i remember you don't think you don't
agree with us
you're
defining womanhood
is
just a project of someone who identifies
as a woman yeah but what like what do
they identify instead of saying what do
they identify as they identify as a
woman but what is that
i honestly don't know a woman has its
own duty and a man has his own duty and
a lady cannot duty the duty of a man and
a man cannot do a duty of a woman
can a man
if you want to become a lady but your
man
you have something wrong something wrong
something wrong in your family from the
wrong in you right and that's fine if
you have something wrong if you have
gender dysphoria we're not gonna no one
wants to string you up and and end your
life for it but stop trying to make it
seem like it's something that it's not
yeah no i'm tired of it it's just
annoying yeah this will get deleted in
30 seconds met a four-year-old
who believes in santa claus
so this is someone who believes that
a fat man is traveling through the sky
on a flying reindeer at lightning speed
coming down his chimney with presence
yeah
would you say that this is someone who
maybe has a tenuous grasp on reality
they have an appropriate four-year-old
handle on their reality that's very real
for them agreed agreed but santa claus
is real for them but yeah santa claus is
not actually real yeah well and but
santa claus does deliver their christmas
presents
oh yeah but he's not real though
to that child they are
when i see a child who you know lives in
santa claus and then let's say this is a
boy and he says i'm a girl
this is someone who can't distinguish
between fantasy and reality so
how could you take that
as a reality
i would say that as a pediatrician and
as a parent i would say nah there's no
way this girl's a doctor just
let's go how wonderful my four-year-old
and their imagination is
what about if someone wasn't okay okay
okay how wonderful my four-year-old and
their imagination is so again she just
admitted that a little boy who thinks
he's a girl is imagining it imagining it
and then she's also gonna argue that
it's that it's real and that little boy
really is a girl can't have both ways
pumpkin non-binary
you know that pumpkin was nonstick
not a pumpkin like someone is
you're not a woman you're not a man
yeah someone's like someone is neither
there's something else is that
he's saying we have never seen things
like this for a man he has a penis for a
woman he has a vagina so this is a lady
this is a man what if it's a woman with
a what if it's a woman with a penis
[Laughter]
i love how these people i can't even
comprehend how [ __ ] absurd this is
right we've been listening to it for
years and we can't comprehend it either
could you imagine like just this guy
just falling out of this guy in his
helicopter coming in and trying to talk
to you about this nonsense i i don't
even know what to say to this stuff this
this is just ridiculous it's
embarrassing i'm embarrassed by it i am
i i find the whole conversation absurd
and embarrassing i'm just disappointed
keep going get the money they're getting
control
sorry
people are laughing is that is that a
dumb question
what do you ask
no no back it up talk to marci bowers
first of all what if it's a woman with a
penis
what what
these are like the happiest people too
yeah because they're not worried about
all this they don't have these
ridiculous problems they have simple
problems like where what am i going to
eat sorry you're a world renowned
gynecologist and surgeon you're also a
transgender woman that's a transgender
tell me a little bit holy [ __ ] did you
did you notice that
now that i see it
yeah but
i couldn't tell no i didn't notice at
first now
well i mean i i identify as a woman
but
you're a woman right i'm a woman with i
mean that's my life
day to day
but i have a transgender history
let's say if you want to sleep a woman
definitely you'll do sex
search the woman and you the fighting is
it
but for the man where do you
you ask that question
i don't know all the logistics of it
based on what i'm saying would you ever
want to move to america
[Laughter]
[Music]
what is a woman
a woman
is a
you know it's a combination of your
physical
attributes and then what you're showing
to the world and the gender clues that
you give
and hopefully those match your gender
identity
the
critics on the other side of this
of uh of this of this issue there aren't
many
but go ahead there aren't many who
would disagree with what you're saying
about
well you know the dinosaurs of the world
are certainly out there
well she lives in a bubble
male gametes that's what makes me male
no your your sperm don't make you male
then what does
it's a constellation
in reality
in truth okay whose truth are we talking
about the same truth that says we're
sitting in this room right now you and i
no
you're not listening if i if i see a
chicken laying eggs and i say that's a
female chicken laying eggs did i assign
female or am i just observing a physical
reality that's happening in the world
does the chicken have gender identity
does a chicken cry
does a chicken commit suicide
let's say
because you're talking you're trying
chicken has sex like anything like
anything
an assigned gender
but a chicken doesn't have a gender
identity so we assign female to chicks
when they lay eggs that's it we assume
they're female if they lay eggs that's
biology it's a female male chickens
don't lay eggs i'm just pissed off
i don't even know like what do you want
me to say oh do this one no
we're going to finish this video
meathead come on we were done
[ __ ] man that's so annoying i mean
whatever it's not i guess it's not
annoying
whatever they want look there's there's
like a boxing clip can we just watch
something with some testosterone for a
minute something [ __ ] normal just for
a sec
dropping thomas to the canvas
it was a brutal and absolute victory
in his autobiography tyson later said
that he hit pinkland with everything he
had
not caring what would happen to him
amazing are you done
we're done
all right
i told you let me handle it you gotta
back off [ __ ] man stop going on your
phone we're filming a video what's wrong
with you the next thing what do you
think you're the only person in the
world the next thing we have to finish
this one oh okay oh my god what is up
with your head did you just get like did
you lose brain cells from that video or
something i did i did and i was trying
it i was trying to un-poison myself it's
like you took drugs and you don't even
know what's going on right now all right
give a final thought or something yeah
we gotta watch more of that guy i'll
give you some final thoughts talk to me
like that again
all right [ __ ] that was
horrible to watch
all right it's done it's not i'm not
watching anymore that [ __ ] for a while
because i unless you just want to sit
here and watch boxing old boxing matches
that's fine i'll do that let me know if
you want to see more boxing or more
controversial stuff like matt walsh
remember to like subscribe join the
discord in my comments and i love you
all
say something funny stop saying that
it's not
[Music]
the funny i'd rather writing on the wall
won't last long